[Music]
hey vixens welcome back to Sweetwater
secrets your ultimate source for all
things Riverdale now I'm Liana Galera
and this is our preview show for episode
202 chapter 15 Nighthawks so do not
worry there are no spoilers here however
I will be giving you guys some inside
scoop from Riverdale's HBIC
Madeline Peck and discussing your best
fan theories and episode reactions so
far for season 2
but first the teams in Riverdale are
always playing detective and now it's
time to put your skills to the test
so here are two truths and a lie from
Camilla Mendes I'm terrified of bees I
didn't know how to swim until I was 8
and I'm allergic to KJ's Cologne alright
guys make your predictions right now in
the comments and we'll see who's right
when I reveal camis big fat lie and just
a bit now guys I loved reading through
all of your comments on last week's
sweet water secrets heck yes I read them
all and a lot of you guys support my
theory that Mary Andrews is somehow
related to the blossom family so yes we
will get to the bottom of this but I was
most excited to see that almost all of
you share my deep hatred for miss Grundy
let's take a look at some of the
comments so I loved the fact that we
have dandy ie who said Grundy gives me
the heebie-jeebies
me too girl Laura 14 says my favorite
part of the episode was Grundy's death
yes I agree my chemical life
a kiss before dying miss Grundy get it
so cheeky girl and Jada Renee said can't
believe Grundy is still into that and
why do I feel like the ex is the guy in
the mask hmm great point because this
leads us to our other masked-man
theories now Ella Bradley said I think
the sheriff is the guy in the mask
whereas Gabriela Venusian said um okay
who thinks that the person who shot Fred
and killed miss Grundy is actually
trying to hurt Archie by hurting or
killing the people he loves who knows
what's next
that is a great Theory girl I also love
Katerina Rodriguez says am I the only
one who thinks that the man who killed
Grundy looks a lot
like Betty's father interesting so as of
now our main suspects for the man in the
mask are Grundy's ex-sheriff Keller Hal
Cooper or someone else who is out to get
Archie now I don't know who it is but I
would love it if the Cooper's were
somehow involved just so I could get
more Alice in my life also I feel like
there's a weird fixation on the fact
that he has green eyes and I definitely
think that might be a red herring
because archiekins colored context do
exist hon luckily it looks like we'll be
getting closer to the truth in
Nighthawks now taking a deeper peek at
the Nighthawks promo it looks like
moving getting our first Pussycats
performance of season 2 but wait what
what is this yes Cheryl is stepping in
and looking oh so fierce and here's a
quick tease from my chat with Madeline
Pech about joining the Pussycats this
episode take a look odd thing the fact
that in episode 2 miss Cheryl joined the
Pussycats for a hot moment what was that
like for you it was so fun it was
actually super last-minute I'm ever
getting a rewrite and Roberto text me
he's like you're joining the Pussycats
again I was like now fun fact this is
not the first time that Cheryl has
performed with the Pussycats yes that's
right if you remember way back to the
second episode of season 1 Cheryl
actually wrapped a verse of candy girl
at the pep rally
but the moment was cut for the episode 4
time which is insane and I would really
like to be able to see that but whatever
is cool now check back to Sweetwater
secrets after Nighthawks for my full
interview with Mads and my girl Ashley
Marie to get the scoop on their amazing
cover that will be stuck in your head
for days and days plus they're spilling
all about the dangers of dancing on top
of pops now taking it back to my chat
with cami it's time to discover which
fun fact she was full-on lying about let
me give me two truths and a lie about
yourself two truths and a lie I'm
[Music]
terrified of bees
I didn't know how to swim until I was 8
and I'm allergic to KJ's Cologne and the
lie is I'm allergic to Gigi's club
I'm sure KJ smells nice they did oh yeah
yeah good son loves Cologne did you ever
pick out the one that he's gonna wear
for the day no but I always ask him I'm
like what is that because it smells good
I want to tell like and then he'll just
feel like they'd be like no I'm not
gonna share my secret like he won't tell
me what the line is because he wants it
to be only follow your nose to whatever
is KJ exactly ooh
KJ's keeping secrets all right guys now
just a reminder that on every episode of
Sweetwater secrets I'll be bringing you
exclusive interviews with the stars of
Riverdale so check back after you watch
Nighthawks because Madeline Ashley cami
and Lilly are all gonna be weighing in
on the latest episode and hit the
comments or chat with me on Twitter
about the masked man theories give this
video a like and be sure to hit
subscribe on e t--'s youtube channel so
you never miss an episode of Sweetwater
secrets bye guys
[Music]
you